[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
really uh awesome game uh from the uh
graffiti grand swiss being played in
riga latvia currently it's dario
schweitzer versus uh
now we've covered a few of uh
games during the us chess championship
he had that wonderful win against
narudic and also he had a win against
um
lazaro bruzon
and well it was it was a fine event for
him but here he faces a feruja who is
also a well very very deadly opponent so
let's check it out and we're going to
discuss the standings uh after we check
out this wonderful game uh so with the
white pieces opens with e4 we have c5 by
felucia as uh he usually does going for
the most fighting opening uh the
sicilian defense knight to f3 d6 and now
uh d4 we have captures captures knight
to f6 knights the c3 and a6 figure goes
for the knight of variation of the
sicilian and nowadays uh in a lot of
games we just see the atoms attack h3g4
right away but here we have f4 it's the
amsterdam variation against the sicilian
defense uh and it is very very sharp
aimed at going for that e5 push right
away if black allows it and you could
easily go wrong here for example if b5
which is kind of a normal developing
move uh in the sicilian e5 really makes
it problematic for black to play this
for example captures captures knight d5
we're going to play e6 and what do you
play now well if bishop captures we will
very happily capture this bishop but if
pawn captures bishop d3 already
threatening queen to h5 check if g6 we
capture and so on so it's not not a
great position for black uh but of
course this uh never happens in top tier
games of course ferugia blocks white's
e5 with an e5 of his own uh knight back
to f3 as the knight was attacked and now
queen to c7 you could also play queen to
c7 instead of e5
it's important just that you keep an eye
on the e5 square so bishop to d3 bishop
to e7 and both players castle to safety
so castles castles and king to h1 uh a
nice prophylactic move uh the queen has
access to this diagonal so you do not
want to keep your king and g1 for
example you develop your bishop uh and
then
uh you know okay uh the the bishop would
actually prevent uh any any checks from
from coming but it's always safer to
just play king to h1 uh and now uh
knight beat the d7 also uh if you're
interested about something like bishop
to g4 which is usually a good pin uh
here f5 makes it just a
silly move because next we're gonna play
h3 and you're gonna have to give up this
bishop doesn't matter what black plays
h3 you can't go here because g4 will
trap it so you'd have to play some like
captures captures and now white has the
bishop pair
and well black's remaining bishop will
not be doing all that much white has
excellent control over over the d5
square uh white is um just very very
happy here so instead after king to h1
knight b to d7 is played and now a4
stopping any b5 ideas so knight to c5
and now
uh there are some games where i move
like queen to e1 was played shifting the
queen into the attack uh also f captures
an e5 is a known move but here we have
a5 by
and it is now as of move 12 that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
furuga continues playing this well
bishop to d7 now of course you want to
bring the bishop to c6 as it will be
very powerful on this diagonal so bishop
to e3 and now rook 8 to e8 uh
furuja
feels that his rook is needed on f8
maybe as a defender maybe as uh maybe
this knight will move maybe he's gonna
push the f pawn maybe he wants to open
up otherwise you might even play some
like rook eight to see it and bring this
rook to e8 so many ideas here but okay
uh we have rook 8 to e8 and now queen to
d2 developing the queen connecting the
rooks and now we have e captures on f or
bishop captures and bishop to c6 so now
the bishop is on this wonderful diagonal
and here we have rook f2 e1 with ideas
of executing e5 uh so knight the h5
attacking the bishop here bishop back to
e3 and now bishop to f6 the other bishop
is now very nicely activated as well
and now what do you what do you play
here uh in the game church played bishop
to d4 but very interesting and i will
just show this because it's very
interesting is bishop captures on c5
it's sort of a capture fest uh d
captures on c5 knight d5 attacks the
queen and the bishop here and if bishop
captures e captures uh we can even play
something like c4 and it's a really
really crazy position for example
everything gets traded off rook to e1
now threatening checkmate you're gonna
capture queen captures you don't have
time to pick up the bishop because mate
is being threatened so g6 can be played
and now after bishop to f1 uh you could
even play a move like c3 so probably the
reason uh white uh why white uh decided
not to go for this for example if
captures then queen captures on a5
you're going to capture this pawn as
well or you could play c4
let's say queen captures knight captures
and then you have this position the
material is equal but white has doubled
c pawns and well the
outside pass pawn is just very very
strong here so black would have a much
much better end game here uh
something that could occur after a move
like bishop captures on c5 so bishop to
d4 and now we have bishop capture sunday
for knight captures and now knight back
to f6 so putting more pressure on the e4
pawn and now knight to f5 asking furuja
will you capture that e4 pawn and it
seems like it's possible to capture it
uh there are some threats here like
queen g5 could be very nasty but it
seems like um it should be fine because
after knight captures the knight
actually covers the g5 square and if
knight captures we're going to capture
with the knight again covered this
square and if queen f4 with idea of
shifting the queen somehow into the
attack we can just play knight c5 back
and now if queen g5 f6 defends
everything but it's a lot of moves and
it's an
ugly position to consider
uh so it is possible but furuja goes for
a different plan he plays rook to e5 and
now okay we have queen g5 threatening
checkmate and now knight to e6 attacking
the queen guarding the g7 square queen
to h4 and now we have queen to d8 if
needed now even a queen trade might be
offered so rook to f1 and now king to h8
uh
just getting the the the king to a safer
square and uh fortunately for black
there's no way to take any advantage of
this like if even if you capture on g7
king captures there's there's no good
way to like remove the king from the
defense of the knight for you to be able
to capture this so for the moment such
things are not possible so here we have
rook 8 to e1 adding another defender to
d4 pawn and now knight the g8
we have queen to g3 now the queen trade
is being offered but queen g3 which uh
decides that uh you know queens
remaining on the board is favoring white
and now g6 pushing the knight back as
well 93 and now knight to f6 so furuja
consolidates a little bit as that was
not an easy position for him
but knight c4 is coming and now what do
you play if you move the rook well then
we just pick up the d6 pawn it's a
backwards pawn it's a very weak pawn uh
so uh instead of moving the rook
somewhere like rook to g5 we have knight
to h5 taking away the f4 and g3 squares
from the white queen and now you don't
have to worry about losing that pawn
however
queen to e3 and now you still have to
move the rook rook to g5
and then now comes rook to e2
just adding a defender to the second
rank but also preparing a rook lift
maybe with rook e to f2
very interesting here is just rook to d1
preparing bishop to e2 and then just
continuing the attack on that d6 pawn
as as was the plan all along but uh he
uh decides to switch his um focus with
rook to e2 now comes rook to g4
uh saying that okay my queen is not
coming to h4 and i'm very very happy
about that so rook e to f2 doubling up
here and afiruja goes queen to h4 all
the same and now what's the idea here
can rook captures on f7 be played uh is
there any uh danger here or a move like
knights to g3 well rook captures on f7
is actually a dead draw uh it was not
played in the game but i will show it
because it's really a lot of fun
captures and captures and now after
night the g3 check uh well you can just
play king to g1 so that knight the g3
check doesn't really do anything what
black would have to play here is knight
to g5 attack the rook here and now after
the rogue goes back we're going to play
bishop captures on e4 and now queen d4
check king the g8 knight captures any
for knight captures bishop captures rook
captures and now queen to d5 check
and we're gonna have this king g7 queen
f7 check king h6 and queen f 8 check
where we're gonna have a nice perpetual
here because white of course uh cannot
go black cannot go down the board he's
gonna get checkmated and well he's just
gonna have to settle for this so uh it
would be
an interesting idea about rook captures
on f7 and for these guys this is very
easy to calculate of course he knows
this would be a draw so he goes knight
to e2 adds the defender to the g3 square
so you don't have to worry about knight
g3 and now uh furuja needs to decide uh
does he
have to worry about the f7 pawn does he
want to defend it does he want to push
f5 and maybe just get rid of the
weakness altogether uh he decides to go
back queen to e7 and defend his pawn but
now comes knight to d4 now it's
important to remove this knight it's
defending the d4 square we kind of need
that to start putting pressure on the
black king so king to g8 gets off of
this diagonal and now knight captures
and c6 we're going to grab the bishop
now because well we don't need the d4
square anymore b captures uh and now
it's a really really tricky moment where
uh if you ask
any engine you know any decent engine
the engine will tell you yes white is
just you know spectacular here white is
crushing uh but i will not show you uh
what uh you know uh white uh uh
what a an angel wants to play and it's
not easy for a human to you know
consider such things so bishop to e2
attacks the rook rook to g5 and now b4
first you defend your a5 pawn you don't
care about what black does as there's
really not all that much black can do so
black might go for an active move like
d5 we we're gonna capture this captures
capture is now knight to b6 and white is
just uh amazing here because you're
gonna eliminate the a6 pawn or uh you're
gonna have to defend it somehow let's
say d4 attacks the queen queen d2 and
now queen to b7 uh but not just bishop
to c4 and white's position is just
crushing
uh yes uh you you have to be careful
here somewhat but after some like queen
e2 queen f3 we're gonna get rid of this
queen we're gonna capture the a6 spawn
and white's position will be completely
winning so if you ask an engine he's
gonna say yes this is not completely
winning but uh uh as we already uh
figured uh you know uh humans are not
engines so here we have e5 uh but this
e5 move although it provokes some
weaknesses for example if d5 knight to
d6 can be played uh it also allows first
a really really awesome resource so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this amazing resource for alireza
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
uh after this e5 uh move was played uh
the knight actually became a target
because now using the fourth rank you
can put pressure on this knight so here
alireza plays queen to h4
congratulations to everyone who found
this this is the only way for black to
continue fighting in the game uh uh you
know needless uh to say this you you are
a true fighter uh now you're threatening
many things of course knight to g3 check
still uh still in the air as there is no
knight i need to be guarding that and
also we're just threatening rook
captures knight on c4 so you have to
defend against one of those threats rook
to f3 is played preventing knight to g3
but now firuji just picks up the knight
bishop captures and he also grabs the
bishop so he wins two pieces for the
rook uh and he's very happy about that
we have e captures on d6 first also now
gets a beautiful pass pawn here uh and
the queen to d5 going after this pawn uh
so queen to f2 now with a triple attack
on the f7 square and now uh you could
defend it now f5 is actually very good
because you don't have to worry about uh
you know this tripling of pieces on the
f file uh but firuja says nope knight to
g5 first we have rook to d5 attacking
and defending the past pawn but now
queen captures on a5 we have d7 a very
very dangerous pawn and now knight to e6
we have to keep an eye on this um uh d8
square at all times we rook the d6
church with a very dangerous threat of
just rook captures uh if captures and
queen captures an f8 checkmate so knight
h k knight h the g7 now the knights are
protecting each other uh so rook
captures on c6 and now queen to d5
attacking the rook but also this pawn so
rook captures an a6 queen captures on d7
and now rook to a7 adding more pressure
here to the f7 square and you have to
defend it uh with queen to e8 so now
this is nicely defended and we still
have two knights for a rook but uh now
has a past c and a pass b pawn uh but uh
you know in order for them to work you
actually have to push them they are only
worthy as much as you push them so here
c4 interestingly he doesn't start with
b4 uh so here we have knights to f5 now
blocking the queen so you don't have to
worry about any threats here on the on
the f7 square and only now b4 so you
have to push those past pawns otherwise
you know they're really nothing
queen to c6 and now we have rook to c1
the rooks belong behind past pawns so
even some like rook a1 to b1 might be
played and now the rooks
will be very nicely placed so knight e
to d4 and now the knights are really
spectacularly placed that they're
defending each other there's no way for
whites to make any progress here uh if
you play something like c5 then you will
not be able to push the pawns any
further if you play b5 then we can just
play knight captures on b5 as the rook
here is unguarded so it's not easy for
white to continue pushing those pawns so
here we have rook to a1 or rather rook
to a2 uh adding uh just more defense to
the second rank but also preparing rook
to b2 to start pushing that b pawn uh
we've worked at e8 now with ideas of uh
just landing that rook as uh
as deep into the position as possible so
rook to b2 and now queen to e4 now uh
the e2 square has become available to
the to the uh black knight we have b5
switch starts pushing his pass pawn and
now comes knight the e3 by ferruja also
interesting is just knight to e2 because
this comes with a threat and it's not
that easy to avoid this threat actually
you have to you know give give up the
the rook here for the night if you try
something like rook c to be one to you
know keep everything safe we're just
gonna play queen to g4 and now this is a
big big problem for you uh
what do you play i mean a move like
knight to g3 check will force h captures
on g3 queen h5 will be checkmate as this
knight covers the g1 square so you're
going to have to cover this um third
rank but the dangerous queen captures on
c4 and even if b6 we can just play
knight to c1 it's a really really
powerful powerful move attacking the
rook if the rook moves we then go
knights here attack the queen and you
don't have to worry about this past pawn
so really after this knight to e2 movie
will have to capture the knight and then
we'll see some like queen captures queen
captures rook captures and after b6 yes
it looks like a very scary past pawn but
the knight on c6 will be a perfect
defender c5 we're gonna go knight c6 and
you don't have to worry rook to b1 we're
gonna play king f8 and after this move
we can just play rook to e8 so nice
everything is nicely defended and
nowhere in the world for you here so
after b5 uh knights the e2 was actually
a very good resource alireza played
knight to e3 it's also a very nice
resource
queen to e1
and now comes queen to f4 so now he has
ideas of knight to g4 maybe and followed
by just checkmating the white king so
queen to g3 offering a queen trade and
queen to f6 just removing um this idea
from the board and now if the knight
moves that rook could be in trouble so
we have rook to e1 putting uh just more
pressure on this knight here and the
king to g7 here alireza plays king to g7
because he wants to be able to move this
knight without facing rook captures on
e8 with check
but again it was possible to go for
something like knight d to f5 attack the
queen and after queen f2 now rookie four
is uh a a very deadly idea attacks the c
for pawn and as white needs those pawns
to actually try to win the game for
example now knight g4 is just crushing
uh the queen is being attacked and after
you move the queen also you have to keep
an eye on the rook so after some like
queen f1 queen e5 attack threatens
checkmate then after g3 just queen
captures on v2
uh you you fall apart completely of
course the rook cannot be captured
because now even this is checkmate uh
but okay furuja wanted to keep his king
safe i don't know the exact situation on
the clock here but it's already moved 53
so i imagine they're already very low on
time uh so here instead uh after this we
have queen to f2 now just offering a
queen trade uh after king to g7 was
played and now only now we have knight d
to f5
and now what do you play here well this
was white's last chance to play a move
like h3 because h3 is a very important
defending pawn here however in the game
rook beat the b1 was played to get the
rook out of harm's way so the white
queen can move but now the position is
completely winning for furuja so feel
free to pause the video and win it while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on listening to what
i've been saying and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
knight to g4 now the idea uh goes
through because uh now the rook captures
rook is not possible the king is not
here so it will not come with check
and your queen is hanging so you have to
move the queen queen f4 was played now
queen to h4 putting a lot of pressure on
the h2 pawn on the rook here
so what do you play here of course if
you play something like rook captures 98
which is possible knight f2 check just
picks up the queen so we can't have that
so instead rook to f1 was played but now
we have rook to e4 again offering a rook
but the idea is the same if the queen
moves we're just going to play queen
captures an h2 checkmate the queen is
needed here at all times to defend the
h2 pawn so here we have queen to c7
still guarding that h2 pawn but now
comes the the the master move knight
captures on h2 and this is beautiful
yeah it's uh like ending the game with a
joke uh saying that if you capture my
knight then it's a beautiful smothered
mate knight the g3 check king to g1
knight to e to check of course the f2
square is covered so you have to go back
queen captures an h2 king captures and
the rook to h4 is checkmate the knight
covers g1 and g3 squares this is forced
so
of course capturing the knight is
impossible king the g1 was played in the
game but now furuja just collects
material knight captures an f1 rook
captures and the rook captures on c4
attacking the queen queen e5 check
ferruja played queen to f6 and he was in
this position on move 61 that daru
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he's down uh
material he's done a full piece uh and
well this past pawn will not um
be able to to do anything here uh if you
if you try and trade here for example
captures captures and rook b1 to try and
push that pass pawn rook c7 takes care
of everything pawn to b6 rook b7 and you
have all the time in the world to
win this spawn and of course the
position is easily winning
so another a fine game from round two of
the
feedhhs.com grand swiss and
it's going to be very very interesting
in round three fabiano karwana who drew
the game uh
the one that we've shown uh tanika sarin
will be facing even shahrich uh so in
round three the only people with actual
two out of two are even charged already
and alexander pretka after that
beautiful beautiful queen sacrifice so
we're going to see what happens um
uh
it's going to be it's going to be pretty
a while there's alireza faces and karana
faces even charge so we'll see what
happens in round three those are the top
boards uh we'll see if anyone can
uh who will remain on to uh out of two
if anyone uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it thank you all
once again for recommending such such
wonderful games i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to allison and i
would like to thank micah kennedy
gustavo fernandez thc ollie.nl and
george norsworthy for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes
checking up any wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world and so i don't forget uh here are
the
nope those are the wrong standings let
me just uh
huh all right remind me to show you uh
not the standings but the uh you know
live elo rating uh changes uh you know
for a place of players above 2700 in the
next one uh i i thought i prepared it
for this one but it seems i haven't now
but yeah thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day